[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
the johnny depp versus amber heard saga
continues as against amber heard we the
jury award compensatory damages in the
amount of 10 million dollars why heard's
attorneys say a juror improperly served
in the case and the delhi yuvaldi school
shooting i'm using this pain to speak to
you today as a uvaldian
and to speak for the parents and victims
who seek the truth
transparency and ultimately
accountability an area pediatrician
addresses the shooting psychological
fallout plus colorado vs kevin eastman
the messages pretty much said that he
was married to mrs
frank
to leave her alone
or he was going to can i say it yes he
was going to kill me a victim's friend
testifies about previous threats from
the defendant and later police in
philadelphia search for a group of
children who beat an elderly man to
death with a traffic code lawn crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to long crime daily i'm
your host brian buckmeyer attorneys for
amber heard now claim a juror was served
improperly in the actress's recent
defamation trial against ex-husband
johnny depp
last month a virginia jury ruled largely
in favor of depp awarding the movie star
15 million dollars in damages the jury
awarded her to only two million dollars
in compensatory damages the lawsuit
stemmed from herd's 2018 washington post
op-ed saying she was a survivor of
domestic abuse depp filed a 50 million
dollar lawsuit claiming his ex-wife
defamed him by manufacturing stories of
abuse heard pushed back with a counter
claim of a hundred million dollars
noting depp was never mentioned by name
in the article heard's attorneys now say
newly discovered facts show issues with
juror number 15. while a judge ruled the
juror's names would be temporarily
sealed heard's attorneys say the juror
who took part in the trial has the same
last name as the person called and lives
at the same address in a memo filed last
week attorneys for heard wrote in part
quote it's deeply troubling for an
individual not summoned for jury duty
nonetheless to appear for jury duty and
serve on a jury heard's attorneys now
argue her due process rights were
violated when a person not summoned for
jury duty appeared they say a mistrial
should be declared for the defamation
suit on monday depp's attorneys filed a
motion to strike this request
joining us today is palm beach county
state attorney dave ehrenberg and
co-host terry austin dave it must be a
civil thing because we can never get
people to show up for criminal jury duty
but let's jump into this if the mistake
is that the wrong person showed up but
they were properly selected
does that still create a mistrial
no no mistrial uh as long as you have
voidier which is jury selection you
could vet the juror and the juror was
acceptable to both sides so what that
you had an honest mix-up now if there
was something nefarious where you have
this guy he he went just for the sole
purpose of ruling for johnny depp and he
somehow knew that that was the case he
was going to be selected for but i can
pretty much assure you that this was an
honest mistake he took his father's
subpoena he went to court and he was
vetted and questioned and accepted by
both sides no mistrial all right dave
you want to show up to any for jury duty
any time for me um let's do that now
terry how do you think the judge will
respond to this because what david's
saying makes perfect sense to me it's
like a harmless error type of situation
but will there be a hearing to question
the juror
absolutely not david's 100 right that
judge should dismiss the motion outright
in order to prevail on emotion like that
there has to be some prejudice and there
has to be a violation of amber heard's
rights there were no violations here
there's no prejudice there's no need to
question that juror there's no need for
a hearing these jurors are selected
randomly usually with the driver's
license or with a voter registration and
as david said as long as there is a voir
dear and that juror answered the
questions honestly and there was no
misconduct absolutely this should go
forward and we should definitely not
have a mistrial i think the judge is not
going to have a hearing and he's going
to just dismiss that motion outright
yeah but hey the defense has to make the
motion you have to represent your client
you got to get the paces i just don't
think it's going to go anywhere well in
other celebrity news tesla's ceo elon
musk and social media giant twitter
could soon face off in a court battle
after the spacex founder says he's
backing out of a deal to purchase the
site musk made the move in april to
purchase twitter for 44 billion dollars
saying the site was limiting free speech
he said he wanted to take the company
private arguing he would be able to grow
twitter and make it more politically
neutral musk and his lawyers now say
he's backing out of the deal accusing
twitter of withholding information about
the number of spam and bot accounts on
the platform in the merger twitter and
moz had agreed if he were to back out he
would pay 1 billion dollars in fines
musk and his attorneys will have to
prove twitter breached the agreement in
order to not pay that fine twitter
claims it was being truthful about spam
accounts numbers on friday the social
media giant said it plans to sue musk to
complete the sale saying it's confident
it would win in court
and in other celebrity news rapper kanye
west faces new legal issues over
allegedly failing to settle outside
outstanding fees owed to a high-end
fashion rental service the lawsuit was
brought by david cassevant archive a new
york based stylist whose private
collection focuses on men wear that can
be rented the stylist is suing west for
more than four hundred thousand dollars
saying west didn't return various rare
esteemed pieces of designer clothing
which he borrowed dating back to october
of 2020. court documents say west owes
the david cavian or cassavant archive a
little more than 220 000 in unpaid fees
the additional 195 thousand
is to replace the items if they are all
lost entirely the news of this new
lawsuit comes just a week after wes was
also sued for alleged copyright
infringement for his new album donda ii
that complaint argues west sampled a
1989 song in his latest work without
consent or compensation
in celebrity news overseas prince harry
scores a victory in a defamation case
against uk
tabloid last week a british judge sided
with the prince saying parts of an
article published in the british
publication of the mail defamed the duke
of sussex the article discussed prince
harry's legal battle against the
government after it denied his request
to pay for police protection while his
family is in britain when prince harry
and his wife meghan markle stepped down
steps back from their royal duties in
2020 their family lost its publicly
funded security after that prince harry
offered to pay for security while in
britain but was denied on friday an
english judge ruled in prince harry's
favor in the initial phase of his libel
case
still ahead on law and crime daily a man
stands trial for a demo homicide in the
state of colorado but first the uvalde
sheriff testifies about the deadly
school shooting when we could expect to
see a preliminary report about the
massacre
[Music]
welcome back officials in texas agreed
to release surveillance video from the
delhi vaulting school shooting this as
the city sheriff's testifies in front of
the state house committee back in may an
18 year old gunman opened fire at rob
elementary school in uvalde texas 19
students and two teachers were killed in
the massacre the gunman was also killed
17 others were injured in the days
following the shooting spree law
enforcement faced public scrutiny for
their failure to react quickly reports
say it took more than an hour for a
place to take down the shooter as
multiple 911 calls were made from inside
the school and several students inside
yelled to police who were outside while
the house committee investigates a law
enforcement response 20 officers have
been called to testify on monday the
uvalde sheriff gave testimony via zoom
in a closed door hearing officials say
the preliminary report on the shooting
could be released in the next 10 days
this as uvalde pediatrician addressed
the massacre at a white house press
conference on monday applauding recently
passed gun control legislation
it's been tough being a pediatrician in
a community where children do not want
to return to school and parents want to
send them there with the fear of a
future attack
i see children daily with ptsd and
anxiety that's now leading to depression
i spend half my days convincing kids
that no one is coming for them
and that they are safe knowing
and they are safe but how do i say that
knowing that the very weapons used in
the attack are still freely available
let this only be the start of the
movement towards the banning of assault
weapons
as i have said before adults are
stubborn we're resistant to change even
when the change will make things better
for ourselves
but especially when we think we're
immune to the fallout
as we have seen no community is immune
to the fallout
rather the fallout is landing in our
backyard on a weekly basis
terry how broad of an investigation
could this be and what changes do you
believe will follow you know what brian
these types of investigations generally
cast a wide and a very deep net the
texas house of representatives is going
to have very wide latitude they're going
to thoroughly investigate this case
they've already said that they want to
take a look at that hallway surveillance
video and they want footage to be
accessible to the public because they
think it's necessary for the public to
understand what happened they're going
to call as many police officers and
other witnesses as they deem necessary
and you better bet they're going to look
at police policies police procedures to
try to determine whether or not they
followed all of those procedures
now dave this blew my mind i think it's
going to do the same thing for you but
the chair of the committee
representative dustin burroughs is
prohibited from releasing the 77-minute
quote-unquote hallway video because of
an nda with a sheriff's department does
that make any sense and is that right
it's frustrating brian but i understand
how investigators including the da's
office are reluctant to release this
video while there's an ongoing
investigation now the killer is dead but
there's an investigation going on about
possible criminal conduct by people
around who stood around and did nothing
so as long as that is possible where you
could have culpable negligence or child
neglect i can understand why they're not
going to release that video yet because
you don't want the potential suspects to
corroborate their stories to lock down
on some story after they watch the video
and you also don't want them to flee if
they think they're about to be charged
and that's why you're a prosecutor and
i'm a public defender you're making the
right choices it makes a lot of sense
dave and in political news president
biden signs an executive order to
protect abortion rights
president biden signed the order on
friday in the wake of roe versus wade
being overturned the order allows health
and human services to protect access to
contraception and medication abortion
while maintaining patient privacy
president biden also says the white
house will create a task force on
reproductive health care through which
federal agencies could offer support for
states with legal protection for
providers and for out-of-state patients
at a press conference president biden
explained the executive order saying
abortion rights could only be restored
by voting
the only way to fulfill and restore that
right for women in this country is by
voting
by exercising the power at the ballot
box let me explain
we need two additional pro-choice
senators and a pro-choice house to
codify roe as federal law
your vote can make that a reality
i know it's frustrating
and it made a lot of people very angry
but the truth is this
and it's not just me saying it it's what
the court said
when you read the decision the court has
made clear
it will not protect the rights of women
period
period
after having made a decision based on a
reading of a document that was frozen in
time in the 1860s
when women didn't even have the right to
vote
the court now
now
practically dares the women of america
to go to the ballot box and restore the
very rights they've just taken away
coming up on law and crime daily
security videos shows a group of
teenagers attacking an elderly man or
the traffic cone in philadelphia plus a
colorado man stands trial for a double
homicide the latest developments in the
trial of kevin dean eastman
[Music]
back a friend of one of the victims in
the colorado trial of kevin eastman
takes the stand telling jurors a
defendant had threatened him before he
allegedly killed his ex-girlfriend and
her new love interest eastman is charged
with two counts of first-degree murder
tampering with the deceased human body
and tampering with physical evidence for
allegedly killing heather frank and
local greely colorado musician stanley
scott sessions on separate days in
february 2020. frank and eastman both
had arrest warrants in connection to
sessions murder before frank's body was
found prosecutors say eastman slit
session's throat in frank's apartment
and that eastman fatally shot frank to
silence the only witness to sessions
killing investigators say eastman burned
session's body and was allegedly
preparing to burn frank's body as well
when he was arrested at a gas station on
friday frank's friend testified for the
prosecution he told the jury eastman had
threatened him while he was spending
time with frank
can you tell the jury what those
messages said
the messages pretty much said that he
was married to mrs
frank
to leave her alone
or he was going to can i say it yes he
was going to kill me
he was going to stab me in the face
in the neck
he was a rough neck he worked in the oil
field blah blah blah
and i was texting him back and forth and
i was like whatever you know
you guys have your own issues
but that's when
i blocked him because i didn't know what
the next step would be we kind of
cut off all contact
okay heather and i because i didn't want
to be a part of that i was i was going
through my own things
and i was just like this is toxic i
never knew she knew she had
him
because she never talked about it
you know she never talked who she was
she said like if they're you know i
didn't know they're married when like he
said either married
what she did say is that he would show
up at the doug's diner quite often
unannounced
you know so that's where it kind of
started and she was in fear because she
could never get away from him he was
always
kind of lurking in the background
all right terry and dave we've been
talking about this testimony all day
terry how does this testimony fit into
east uh into eastman's uh guilt or
innocence in terms of this case
you know i think the testimony is
relevant and i think it's primitive i
don't think it's prejudicial i think
under rule 404 it is allowed i think
that's why the judge allowed it it is
showing motive and i think the motive is
the same this is a prior friend of
heather franks he's saying that he was
threatened by the defendant and that's
exactly what happened with scott
sessions he was threatened and
ultimately killed by the defendant so i
definitely think it should be allowed
and i think the judge made the right
decision all right maybe it's the
defense attorney i mean but i tend to
disagree and dave i love asking a
prosecutor pro-defense question so here
it is i would argue that this
information about eastman threatening a
person
he isn't accused of a crime of doing is
more prejudicial than probative i
threaten this other guy that has nothing
to do with i do with my wife so how does
this come in
this is a tough one brian and terry's
got a good point because it could show
motive you have to establish that this
goes to motive because how else are you
going to show how why eastman kills
sessions why well he was this jealous
dude who was always lurking around and
exaggerating his relationship with frank
so
that's the argument now as a prosecutor
you have to be careful and i'm sorry to
equivocate on this because it is a close
call because if you admit this into
evidence and as a prosecutor if you
don't absolutely have to have this to
prove guilt
then you
could be overturned on appeal and that's
the last thing prosecutors want to do so
it's a close call some prosecutors would
be like hey let's take a step back not
use it because we got other good stuff
instead so it all depends on how
important this piece of evidence is to
make that decision whether to put it
into evidence i'm calling it now i'm
calling it a pellet argument we'll see
whether or not it actually works in the
long run well when we come back a group
of philadelphia teens wanted for murder
still ahead we take a closer look at
security camera footage showing the
children brutally beating an elderly man
to death
welcome back apparel brothers ages 10
and 14 years old turned themselves over
to philadelphia police as part of a
group who beat an elderly man to death
with a traffic cone police released
photos of the children involved and
video of the attack last week hoping
that more information could lead to an
arrest it happened in the early morning
hours of june 24th on the city's north
side security video shows a group of
seven kids who authorities believe were
teenagers beating a 73 year old man with
a traffic cone while police did not
release his name local philadelphia news
outlet identified the 73 year old as
james lampert jr who went by the
nickname simi security video shows
lampert being struck by the code and
falls to the ground he died the next day
a 20 000 reward is now being offered for
details leading to an arrest or
conviction anyone with more information
on the other children involved should
contact the philadelphia police
department homicide division the phone
number is now on your screen
dave this is pennsylvania but if this
happened in palm beach florida what
charges would these young men be facing
the ones who actually threw the cone
at the victim could be charged with
second-degree murder and if they're 16
or 17 years old they could be tried as
an adult the ones who didn't throw the
cones would not be charged most likely
and if they're under 16 they should be
charged as juveniles yeah that'd be
interesting to see whether or not i know
in new york we have this kind of
accomplished liability whether they get
tacked on with that but terry what are
the next steps in this investigation for
the other kids involved
you know now that two of these
teenagers basically 10 and 14
turn themselves in i think the police
are going to focus on them to try to
determine whether or not they can get
information and the information
obviously is identifying the other
people involved and you better believe
those two children are going to be
grilled to find out who is in that group
beyond that i think what the police are
going to do is look at that surveillance
video to determine some facial identity
and to look at the hair one of the
videos showed that one of the children
had a blonde spot in his or her hair and
look at the braids of the girls who had
long braids to identify and the bags
that they were claiming they had some
identification on their shirts and i'll
tell you this that twenty thousand
dollar award will also help because
people will be motivated to give more
information yeah i anticipate a long and
uh detailed investigation of final deal
dave terry thank you very much and thank
you for joining us here on long crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss justice in america
[Music]
you